Today, uh, for our experts
in emotion interview.
We have the honor of
speaking with doctors,
Lita cosmetics and John to be together
who will help us answer the question of
whether and how emotions are products
of our evolutionary history or our
emotions evolutionarily evolved.
So doctor cause and two B are well known
for their work in pioneering the field
of evolutionary psychology.
They're both professors of psychology and
anthropology at UC Santa Barbara where
they co direct the center
for evolutionary psychology.
They began their collaboration 29
years ago at Harvard University,
just undergraduates and have received
since then numerous awards including the
NIH director's pioneer award,
the American Association
for the Advancement of
Science Prize for Behavioral
Research, American psychological
associations, early career award, um,
the national science science foundations,
presidential young investigator
award and Guggenheim fellowships.
So I now turn to a very special one of
a kind duo experts and emotion interview
together with Dr Lita caused
NEIdeas and Dr John Tooby.
So welcome Lita and John, thank you
so much for speaking with us today.
Thanks so much. Thanks for, I guess
what I thought I would do, I'm with you,
is first ask you each a bit about what
first got you interested in studying
emotion, um, and a leader
if you want to go first.
Well we, we started together.
I mean we were trying to,
we were trying to figure out what it
would be to have an evolutionary approach
to psychology more generally.
And you really can't have that
without some approach to emotion.
And we, we talked about it a
lot and we were thinking that,
um, there's a phenomenology of emotion,
which is so real to all of us, right?
But on the other hand, at some point
if you think of the brain is a system,
the processes of probation, there
needs to be some sort of computational,
some sort of information processing
level description of what,
what an emotion is.
What we were thinking is that
if you separate those questions,
just like in envision,
um,
at first people dealt with the
phenomenology of vision and what,
you know is my experience of yellow,
like your experience and be yellow
or and so forth. But when people,
and those are, those are
important questions, but two,
they start to really make progress when
they start to get computational about it.
And so we want it to think,
well,
what would it be to have a computational
approach to emotion with the notion
that at some point you'll understand the
phenomenology but maybe maybe doing the
computational part first would help.
So, uh, what I would say is that, yeah,
the thing about evolutionary psychology,
which is perhaps not widely appreciated,
is that it's very theoretically
principle that, uh,
is this, uh, the, the other westerners
psychological approach to a whole ocean.
Uh,
hello.
Straight forwardly yeah.
Out of, uh, you know,
out of an analysis of how a brain,
which is a,
consist of a lot of different
problems and solving mechanisms would,
or evolutionary time
confronted again and again, we,
with even situations like fighting or
having to form a meat shop or dealing with
sexual infidelity or all
these different situations,
if the mind is full of
different mechanisms,
like your smart phone is full of ass.
Okay. Each one of her function, uh,
they won't all be turned
on. Uh, always, uh,
in all situations, right? Some
situations where you are, uh, you know,
there's a perimeter around more you
have to turn off the vigilant system.
You have to increased heart rate because
you're going to have to flee if you
identify which direction
the present Cruz in it's on.
So it's a what emotions are,
are there modes of operation or a,
an orchestration of all the different
mechanisms turning some off,
turning assignments in particular
situations which are particularly well
designed to deal with the challenges
of keeping the situation. Um,
and so for example, if somebody is
taking your stuff with beating you up,
then uh,
anger Russian system turns on you need
to defend yourself. You need to, uh,
uh, perhaps the cap, the
other person. Um, and uh,
so that's going to be very different
than what you would do if you're dealing
with your newborn and trying to make
sure that it's going to be fat, right?
So not just the physiology changes,
that's just one set of mechanisms,
but all sorts of other things.
Uh,
in terms of memory is almost every
feature speecher of psychology.
Your name will be tweaked,
uh,
into a mode which is the
evolutionary longterm best. Yeah.
Dealing with that kind of situation.
Thank you.
So actually I wanted to ask you both a
bit more about your research here. I mean,
you're both well known for pioneering
this evolutionary approach to
understanding emotion.
And you've already alluded a bit to some
of the fundamental principles of this
approach,
but I wondered if you might just say a
bit more and as well as how do we define
what an emotion is according to an
evolutionary approach that makes it unique
from this perspective?
Well, we, we think of it as a,
as a super word program
that when it kicks in,
they're happening situation detectors,
parts of the system that say,
am I in this particular situation?
So for example,
is it a recurring thing,
something that's happened,
a lot of no particular local situation,
the threat by a Predator or somebody
treating me badly or somebody has treated
me much better than I
ever expected and I'm,
I'm grateful and how then do y?
How then should I deal with that
person? That's what when we buy, buy,
buy situation, it should be
trigger a whole set out a
signal. Maybe part of that,
maybe part of our conscious experience
of emotion is the experience with that
signal.
I don't know.
But that's one hypothesis.
But to a lot of different
mechanisms that are honing.
So let's say let's take the
simplest of um, it's dark,
you're alone and there are
creaking noises outside
whether somebody is coming
break into your house or not.
Lots of things change.
Your hearing becomes more acute.
You notice sounds that you
would never have noticed before.
Inferential processes get turned on.
So was that a random set
of noises or was that,
what steps do you remember?
Uh,
you retreat from memory is all kinds of
information that is relevant to figuring
out whether you're under threat or
not under threat and what to do. Um,
you might have, uh, you know, um,
it might change some of your learning
settings. I'm learning mechanisms,
lots of things that might be changed. So
if you can think of it as a coordinated,
a supportive program that coordinates
a lot of sub programs in a way that's
particularly efficient for
solving that adaptive problem.
But it doesn't have to be something as,
as simple as the Predator situation.
It can be,
there are a lot of interest in
social emotions, um, that can be,
that have to be there to regulate the
kind of complicated social interactions
that we have,
including cooperative ones,
lots of times people focus and an
evolutionary point of view on, on, um,
negative emotions. Um, and those are
certainly, those are very important.
But once I gratitude and, and, um,
you know, gratitude, compassion, uh,
and so forth are as important in
regulating cooperation, for example, as,
as we would argue. Angerness. Um,
all right. So I was going to ask,
you know, from your perspective,
do you feel like this framework applies
to particular class of emotions or you
know, all emotions broadly? I mean,
you're bringing up things as diverse
as gratitude, anger and fear.
Yeah. So, um, yes, we think
it applies to everything.
Is it realistic as possible?
Uh,
so if you start out as Darwin did,
looking at emotion from the perspective
of facial expressions, okay. Uh,
that's, uh, that's a very good start.
But that really limits you because whether
or not an emotion will be paired with
a facial expression, a depends upon
over the evolutionary long term,
whether it was big of broadcast
your internal state or not. Okay.
So we have
a small number of facial
expressions of emotion and we,
I think there's a much larger number of
emotions which are not designed to be
broadcast and therefore didn't devolve
this signal that tells you to tell
everyone around you. I am in this
particular state of mind. Okay.
So some of them, if they're maybe
negative aspects to broadcasting them,
other emotions, it may be the juiciest no
utility to. So for example, wonder, um,
it may be that certain emotions are
there to help organize your adaptations,
to calibrate them and organize them in
certain ways. When you see something, um,
certain kinds of events,
uh,
like a sunset or the stars,
um,
those may be part of what those may
be is a system designed to calibrate
mechanisms in your brain. It's
a very unromantic but, uh,
to calibrate mechanisms of vision and,
and color perception and so forth
on evolutionarily recurrent events,
things that we're reliably
present in the ancestral path.
It could be used to sort
of tune mechanisms, um,
didn't get two of them in the face of a,
the noise of the world as a
simple idea about this is that,
uh, in broadcasting there are test
patterns in the function of it.
Test pattern is too, you already
know what the signal should be,
so then you can treat your equipment
until you see the signal, you know,
you should see, okay. And
revolutionary time always been stars.
Okay. And, uh, so, uh,
the mind knows what they should look
like and therefore if you don't have
anything better or more important to do
and you're a hunter gatherer or sort of
sitting around at night, okay. Uh,
it's kind of mildly rewarding to
look up at the stars. Okay. And, uh,
and then these things,
an infinite optical distance allow
the different revenue topic mass to be
aligned and so on. So it's, so in general,
the aesthetics should be things which
help the brain organizes itself and to pay
attention to, we'll hope to organize
it. And it should be a mildly,
mildly
pleasant because you want to do it,
but you don't, it shouldn't, you know,
uh,
you shouldn't ignore predators.
You shouldn't be more the hunger
crowds of your child for it. Okay.
It should be just the right level when
you have nothing better to do. Right.
So I mean, when you start thinking about
it from an ad, a patient's perspective,
not all emotions are going to be there
for the same kind of class of problem.
Some might be there for very,
very different reason.
And also some things that we don't
think of as emotions might be.
Well thought of as emotions.
Like when you have, when you, uh,
when you get a concussion in your,
um, what's the word I'm looking for?
Hold on when you're in a coma.
Thank you. Okay, so this is works
she fair. When there were
no or traumas. Right. Right.
Yeah. Licensing. Right.
So,
so you shouldn't,
because there might be internal injuries
and moving around with aggravate them.
You shouldn't be not moving at all. Okay.
And you shouldn't be exerting energy.
You're getting excited by other events
that are happening. So the shuts down,
it's a very organic homa
is very organized. Okay.
And we just think of it this
bad ramifications of the
remainder of people who,
uh, unfortunately never leave the state
because they're so damaged. Okay. Right.
Right. But for most people in situation,
so, so you're, you're, you know,
basketball hits you in the head
and you're knocked out. Okay.
That's this system. Uh, and that's
when I was talking earlier about, uh,
starting with facial expressions of
emotions, which is a great to start,
but there's these other things
which have nothing to do with, uh,
signaling to others. And, uh, so
there's a great class of emotions.
He was Accenture to talk about addiction
because you don't have a feeling, right.
But, uh, either, so you don't have the
expression to me, I have a feeling,
but it's an, it's a mode of
operation for the whole system.
It's, it's, you can think of
it as a super order program.
It's just down a lot of different
programs so that all the energy can be put
into your immune system
and into prepare processes.
So weirdly on this perspective of
subordinate programs that are coordinating
other ones, you could think
about Komatsu with emotion,
which is not nine Twitter, but uh, it's
fascinating to think of it that way.
Yeah.
So how would you classify then those
emotions that really do need some sort of
external display, you know, to
signal something to other people.
And what would be those emotions
that really don't require that? Are,
you talked about wonder or what people
call off this idea of a coma in it and it
keeps them anchor. Um, we've
been working, uh, with,
with a lot of our collaborators like
Erin Cell and they know Caesar on, yeah,
Chin. That anger is, I'm triggered
by the perception of somebody.
Somebody is putting much too little
weight on your welfare more too.
They're not taking your welfare into
account to the extent that you think that
they should be given the
nature of your relationship.
And that that should exactly trigger
a whole bargaining and anger as a
bargaining system where you're,
that operates in both cooperative and,
and, and aggressive sort of situations.
But where you were,
if it's a cooperator,
you need to communicate to them
that you don't like what they did,
that it impose costs on you,
that they impose costs on you for a
very little benefit to themselves. No.
And that, that's not okay. And you,
your bargaining basically it activates
all kinds of desires to argue with and
can talk to the person to
argue, to bargain for better
treatment in the future.
So you have basically two ways to bargain
and one way is to say along with the
costs on me, okay, and then you
pay attention to what I want.
Or the other way is in a cooperative
relationship. Uh, you know, it's,
it's conceivable we haven't
experienced ourselves,
but sometimes husbands and wives fight.
Okay.
Never,
never
doesn't mean you're going to
shoot each other ninth each other.
It's that you're in a relationship.
So what marketing power, uh,
so harmony power in a
nonprofit relationships is
this ability to harm the person
who can affect more harm, stronger and so
on. They have more liver leverage. Okay.
Uh,
but in Walker relationships where you
were coordinating your behavior to achieve
a great mutual outcomes, okay. One,
the bargaining power is the extent they
can confer with Walt benefits. Okay.
And so what the what and the anger,
again, cooperative relationships. It's,
it hasn't seen water as a thing except
what you're doing is, you know what,
when somebody's spouse also their base
Chile and it's one that's the external
signal, um, uh, or even beyond that, okay,
but that's the external signal that from
them broadcasting that they think you
haven't put enough weight on their welfare
and therefore they're going to down
regulate the amount of
weight they put on your role
or that there better be a good
reason why they didn't do it.
Hopefully it was for a very large benefit
to the other person. If they weren't,
if they were doing something
that was harming you or not,
taking your welfare can counsel
that needs to be communicated.
If it's not communicated, the whole
point of that adaptation patient can't,
the function cannot be fulfilled
unless there's some sort of a bribe.
And it may be also often
what does it paints?
Anger is information that we're,
that's conveyed where you realize, oh,
the person did not, it's not that they
put two little weight on my welfare,
it's that I misunderstood the situation.
They didn't know they were putting a
cost on me where they didn't do it on
purpose or they did it for a
very large benefit to themselves,
not for something trivial. And then that,
that just, it just sort of the ANC grows,
it disappears
that one.
But that's sort of the system we're
putting weight on each other's welfare,
that those being tied together.
So,
hmm.
MMM.
The wind that, uh, it's a, it's
a delicate interplay and uh,
so each essential, so, so anger, which
seems like a hostel, bad thing. Uh,
and, uh, you know, team has
to be connected to violence,
which would be hard bargaining. Okay. Uh,
actually it's also essential to
cooperation because people make mistakes.
Information processing makes mistakes.
There's always errors. Okay. And so, uh,
it's,
uh,
necessary to communicate your volumes
where things are happening that are not
what you expected in
Muladhara. Okay. And so then,
then you then in fights, people
are, it turns out there are,
are all the gear and sell with this
theory has looked at arguments and the
arguments structure or things like,
uh,
you know,
you hurt me a great deal.
Uh,
I didn't intend to or you
don't have your stand, uh,
I didn't realize that was
important to you. Or alternatively,
you don't understand the full importance
to me of having to do this other thing.
So it's always about the relative costs
and benefits and knowledge states.
And these are acronyms are hurt.
All right?
You can think of it as there
being a grammar to anger
and had the grammar to it.
And that people,
when they're arguing and negotiating the,
they use that grammar both in arguing
with the person that they think harmed
them and with a person responding to them.
The nature of these evolved mechanisms
are their second name or their first
nature to us rate. Uh, and uh, uh,
so we're not necessarily aware
of they're watching. Okay.
So you can do this highly organized
thing in a fight with your spouse and not
know anything about the, your
company. Okay. You feel it.
It's guiding you in certain ways.
It brings up certain concepts.
You remember all the times they didn't
put, we don't and welfare in the past.
You see, it's part of the pattern for
the times. Like really, really helpful.
That's great. Right. So I had a
question for both of you to, which is,
what are the questions right now that
you're grappling with and most excited
about in this domain of,
you know,
emotion and taking an evolutionary
approach to studying it? Well,
many of the things you've been
talking about. Yes. But, uh, the more,
a more general perspective,
this whole idea of bringing the emotions
into the cognitive sciences and,
and trying to get serious about
the computational architecture of,
of emotions so that the top of emotions
is as normal a part of the cognitive
sciences as a study of memory or the study
of attention is because I wa from our
point of view, you can't pull these
things apart. They're all intertwined.
They're all that they're
not only intertwined,
but there is a computational account of
emotion and you won't fully understand
emotion without understanding that in
the same way that you would not fully
understand vision if you were only dealing
with phenomenology and you were not
dealing with the computations that allow
people to recognize objects and know
where they are.
If you didn't know those compensations,
you wouldn't really understand vision.
Totally.
So to make that concrete,
uh,
we think there are certain things we
follow internal regulatory variables like,
okay, uh, I, I'm the weight.
So implicitly my brain is calculating a,
what's the word of this other person
that they're putting on my welfare?
When it's too low, then the brain
triggers, which you going to the anger,
uh,
anger turns on it as a bargaining of
ocean is designed to raise the other
person's a walkup trade off towards you.
Or if that doesn't happen to
lower years towards standards,
but you're not wasting resources on
more energy on somebody who doesn't care
about you. Okay. Uh, then there's,
but at the same underlying variable
welfare tradeoff ratio in yields,
for example, that would be
men, you didn't, you, uh,
something you conduct yourself in
a certain way towards somebody.
It turns out that was really much
worse for them than you expected.
And then you need to be calibrated,
uh,
how much weight you put on your welfare
because you opening to level two level,
uh, well grounded gratitude is where you
find somebody else's but is putting on
larger way done with your welfare
than you've expected and anticipated.
And therefore you need to reciprocate.
Turn up your thumb tr your
ballpark trade off print shows,
no to just submit this new
higher level of cooperation.
And so and so the idea is to map these
magnitudes and the mind in which we now
we can do now and relate them to the
logic of emotions that emotions often play
its role and recalibrating your,
what you're prepared to do or the other
person where your response together
person. And that's why, that's why
we think there's this small app.
Phenomenology is there's
a sort of rob casting,
which she dealt the mechanisms to say,
change your settings on,
on this network of variables because you
have new information about the way the
world is.
And it takes time to feel okay,
so when your mother dies
or something like that,
people want to go away and be alone.
And just,
and so any utilitarian unit,
Darwinian Utilitarian University,
why engage in such spectacular?
We done functional behavior.
Our idea about offices
and some calibration, uh,
requires a lot of process and it takes
time to all the ramifications of the fact
that it, this person was a separate part
of your life and now they're gone. Sure,
sure.
All the different ways in which that
was reflected in your decisions at all,
has to be rerated maybe down new
support would you didn't have before.
So you can feel lonely or anyway,
such, just the question then when you
think about the future of emotion, right?
And you have students coming
up to you and asking you,
so what's in store for the future and
you know, what advice do you have for me?
You know, if I'm thinking
about embarking in this field,
what do you typically tell them?
Okay.
I suggest to them that while they,
they,
if they use your intuitions as, as, uh,
as some guide, but really try
to take very seriously, uh,
the kinds of thinking seriously about
the kinds of adaptive problems our
ancestors had to solve well
in ancestral environments.
Because if you really start
to take those seriously,
you realize that they're
much more complicated than
you would otherwise think.
And it can lead you in new directions
that nobody would think to look before.
So that and,
and also to actually try to get very
specific about what that the architecture
of those programs is going to be.
That's great advice.
Same advice from your end.
Absolutely. I mean it's,
as I say, it's very,
you could make a surprising amount of
sense of the chaos of human behavior if
you take this engineering
first principles approach it.
Mm.
What are recurring out adaptive problems
and what would a assistant as well
designed to deal with those.
And then in the modern world we have
often completely different problems.
And so the behavior looks non functional
or strange or why, why have that?
And uh, but then you can,
when you look at the logic,
you could make sense that that organize
it again around this engineer can spill
it makes enormous sense. And then you
can then explore questions of like,
well then what?
Like what can we,
can we do a little bit of a better with
the world if we understand actually, uh,
principles of your driving
well and even questions like, are certain
things that are considered disorders,
are they really disorders?
Are they the normal functioning of a,
that evolved to do, to
behave in certain ways, to,
to create certain kinds of mental states.
And there are questions like that
about grief and about certain kinds of
depression. There can be very destructive
forms of all of these things. Um,
but it's an,
it's an interesting question.
Are we seeing an extreme form of
something that's really an evolved that a
patient or are we seeing
a disorder, uh, true, um,
dysfunction of an adaptation. And that
can be very helpful in thinking about,
about whether and how to treat
with depression. For example. You
could just see it as a malfunction,
but it might be that it's
a major recalibration will
load so that you've lived
your life in a certain way with certain
expectations would need somewhere and
then you get this big signal that's not
happening and invested in a marriage or
even best,
you know,
you've spent your life trying to get a
in the academia and then you can't get a
job. Uh, okay.
So all the ways you organize your life
on a daily basis in the intermediate
values, your grain in
storage to do certain things.
You now have this powerful signal that
those were a major seventh mistakes. Okay.
And so maybe, uh, we have
no evidence about this,
but it's quite possible
that interfering with, uh,
the recalibration process by drugs or
something you might come out better if you
go through a, we used to have grief
stage of doing this processing. Um,
and uh, rather than to
simply think it's unpleasant,
we should arrest it.
Of course.
What I think the major or
the major depression might
be something else entirely
aware of things that would have brought
you out of bed to ancestrally don't
happen. And I'm not saying
depression is a bit necessary.
I'm just saying you want to understand
the logic of been things are doing or
about functions.
Well,
I just want to say thanks to both of
you for making the time to speak today.
It's been such a pleasure and honor to
hear you both speak about some of these
fundamental principles underlying
where our emotions come from and what
functions they serve for us. So I want
to thank you both for speaking today.
Our pleasure,
and thanks for having us.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with doctor [inaudible] and
doctor John tooby from the University
of California Santa Barbara.
Thank you both so much.
Again.